I told you yesterday or the day before
or like three weeks ago I don't know
time flies that Donald Trump had one
last chance left to prevent his tax
returns from being released to the house
committee investigating him and that
last opportunity was an appeal to the
highest court of the land the Supreme
Court a very right-wing Court in 2022
the Supreme Court has decided to pray at
the altar of trump and indeed judge
Justice John Roberts has delayed the
Handover of Donald Trump's taxes to that
house panel this was the last arrow in
the quiver that Trump had left
and indeed it is on target at least
temporarily the Associated Press
reporting Roberts delays Handover of
trump tax returns to house panel amazing
right but maybe not totally surprising
Chief Justice John Roberts on Tuesday
put a temporary hold on the Handover of
Trump's tax returns to the Congressional
committee Robert's order gives the
Supreme Court time to weigh the legal
issues in Trump's emergency appeal to
the high court filed Monday without
Court intervention the tax returns could
have been provided as early as Thursday
by the treasury Department to the
democratically controlled house Ways and
Means Committee Roberts gave the
committee until wait a second November
10th why is that an important date let
me think November 10th oh there's an
election on November 8th very
interesting the Chief Justice handles
emergency appeals from the nation's
capital where the fight over Trump's
taxes has been going on since 2019
writes the Associated Press remember
lower courts ruled that the committee
has brought authority to obtain tax
returns and rejected Trump's claim that
it was overstepping
um this is uh it are we shocked by this
CNBC also reporting Supreme Court
temporarily blocks Congress from getting
Trump's tax returns
um a very very similar report from CNBC
uh what exactly is going to happen with
this because for years the house Ways
and Means Committee which has absolutely
appropriate
uh constitutionally indicated
investigative responsibilities not just
abilities but responsibilities has been
doing everything correctly and trying to
get a hold of these taxes they've done
everything and it's appeal and obstruct
and block if indeed at this point Donald
Trump didn't think that there was going
to be something damaging to him in those
tax returns why would he still be
working this hard to block their release
what also by the way is the
Constitutional question that the Supreme
Court needs to weigh and think about
where every other judge and court so far
has said no there's no good argument
here the house has brought authority to
obtain tax returns they are doing
everything correctly they should be
turned over every single court has found
that in every venue that Donald Trump
has figured out how to pull into this
mess
but the Supreme Court now needs time
until just 36 hours after the midterm
elections
figure out whether this is actually
appropriate or not November 10th for the
committee to reply what is the purpose
of the block what determines whether the
block stays and how long does it
actually last is this just a Brazen
attempt to get beyond the November 8th
election
without the tax returns being released
no matter what is in there just on the
off chance that there's something
damaging to Trump or Republicans there
could the Supreme Court be that biased
politically to the right given that it
has three trumpous judges on it even
though this was the decision of a
Justice not selected by Donald Trump
Chief Justice John Roberts at this point
I genuinely don't know
but when you read sober
political legal analyzes of this
all of those analyzes come to the
conclusion that at the end of the day
the tax returns should be given to the
house Ways and Means Committee whether
they will find anything
noteworthy there remains to be seen as a
reminder
three most likely elements that would
come from a full review of Donald
Trump's tax returns if indeed they are
provided in full and under adapted would
be number one Trump's not as wealthy as
he claims to be we basically know that
already but it would be confirmation
number two it would confirm what Michael
Cohen and others have been saying for a
long time that for tax purposes Trump
undervalues assets that he separately
overvalues when they are to be used for
collateral purposes that would be number
two
um and then uh I mean and we could go
even further there's many other things I
won't repeat to you the entire list but
the point here is the things we are
likely to learn would not come as an
insane shock but they would be
confirmation of what we've suspected for
a long time also I guess I should
mention that Donald Trump has business
with Shady characters that would be
another and how would we learn that well
he may list assets on tax returns which
we could then cross-reference to other
owners or other business entities that
are involved in the ownership of the
very same assets it would show that
Trump is in business with people we
didn't know about or that he sought to
downplay or whatever the case may be do
I believe that ultimately the house
committee will get the tax returns I do
and by the way I expect them to leak
once the house committee gets them but
it could take a little bit longer when
you're busy during the day and you need
a quick snack sometimes you're just in
the mood for something sweet that's when
I reach for monk pack our sponsor monk
pack offers gooey granola bars that melt
in your mouth as well as nut and Seed
bars that are perfectly crunchy sweet
and salty but the best part is that each
bar is plant-based with only one gram of
sugar two to three net carbs and only
about 150 calories it's great if you're
doing keto or low carb or like me you
just want to minimize your sugar intake
I can't get enough of dark chocolate
cocoa I'm just a chocolate guy it's
great but they come in other flavors too
like sea salt dark chocolate caramel sea
salt they just launched peanut butter
cocoa chip and dark chocolate cocoa if
you don't love monk pack as much as our
entire team does monk pack will give you
your money back go try monk pack keto
granola bars and nut and Seed bars go to
monkpack.com and use the code Pacman for
twenty percent off the link is down
below